foreign
[Music]
Frankie
[__] swear
[Applause]
you thought you could outsmart the high
table
how foolish of here
I'm telling you the truth
I got paid to do a job
that job got [__] up
[__]
surprise that I know
are you even aware of what it is you
stole
[Music]
may I ask you how much you got paid to
steal it
40 Grand
keys to the world for a pittance
not that anyone can put a price on it
the value of an artifact that could
topple an organization that predates the
Roman Empire
what I'm sharing with you is very
privileged information
I only share with one kind of person
to die
what do you want me to do about Cormac
nothing
perhaps this rain is finally coming to
an end
I can't believe
foreign
[Music]